good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Tuesday
we are quarantined we are here we are
alive barely but you know what I'm
really feeling these Quarren times like
I feel like it's really affected my
style um you know cuz I'm going for like
more of just like a relaxed vibe like
I'm not going anywhere after this show
just been like wearing sweats and I'm
just like so feeling my outfit today Wow
Wow I'm a German your outfits really
cute uh my outfits really cute because
mostly this t-shirt I mean long sleeve
that I'm wearing it is new morning toast
merch we've had some delays because
fantasies aren't you know working right
now but we are finding a way to get our
Spring drop to you and this is just one
item from that drop which I am
personally loving yes I wore an item
last week that I think you know some are
some of our more perceptive toasters
realized so there's a lot of good stuff
some some new categories for us you know
we we usually do apparel accessories but
we got we got some weather gear you know
we got some drink we're it's a lot of
good stuff it's a lot of good stuff you
guys will get a preview soon we're just
figuring out the logistics of getting it
to you all during these crazy corona
times crazy corona times and you know
it's another day of the morning shows we
hope everyone enjoyed the movie of the
day yesterday I absolutely adored it
like I can't wait to recap it I have so
many notes about just how fabulous of a
movie it was and how beautiful sunny and
smart it was yes yes yes and like our
whole slate of movies coming up this
week like we have really good ones I'm
also excited to announce today yes I
feel like we found a rhythm of like
underrated movies that we used to love
that we haven't seen in a long time that
hold up and stand the test of time yeah
and you know what at first I thought
that I wanted this movie club club to be
movies I'd never seen before but I
absolutely hate watching new stuff so
I'm the opposite like I wanted it to be
movies I'd never seen before movies that
would make me think I think because like
toes movie of the day started with
shutter island which was such a think
piece and such a masterpiece I wanted
every movie to be like that but that's
the thing about shutter island' like no
other movie is like it which was which
is what makes it so phenomenal yeah and
like I get that genre like movies I
never knew about that like could change
my life but there's just so few of them
and you have to watch so many pieces of
trash
to find the one shutter island' that I'm
not intimated you know what the
quarantine times are stressful enough I
just want to watch stuff that I know I'm
gonna enjoy and last night I literally
smiled from ear to ear like it was such
a fabulous movie it's such a fabulous
movie I can't wait to recap it
yesterday's movie was head over heels
starring Freddie Prinze jr. and Monica
Potter and today we will assign
tomorrow's movie and I'm really feeling
like a new reinvigorated love for the
movie club I'm really excited about it
I'm so happy for you know what I'm
feeling a new reinvigorated love for him
what the redheads book club oh yes
yesterday I started this month's book
which I was seeing like mixed reviews in
the redheads the cover is really weird
if you win is weird if you read the
description it's weird it's like seems
to be like hocus-pocus like magic beasts
like kids being set on fire every Turner
said it was good right she was enjoying
it and Dana's it was Dana's choice and
she is like the best taste in books out
of all of us and her fiance I just read
it and he really likes it and he's like
an intellectual so we were like okay
this is gonna be a good book but
everyone was so skeptical about it
anyways I finished it in one sitting
well I started it maybe at like 8
o'clock and I finished it at 1:30 a.m.
because it was such an easy enjoyable
read like the narrator whose point of
view it was from was so funny I was abs
I was cracking up and there's this one
like saying that you have to suspend
reality for right but they talked about
how crazy it is and it just it is what
it is and it's not even that crazy it's
not like a mystical book it's hilarious
and so I was saying on my story last
night like if you've never been part of
the redheads book club like we are
recording the episode tomorrow and it's
launching on Thursday and like you can
start this book and finish it by the
time the new episode comes out and like
that's just like a fun thing for you to
do during quarantine like you gave
before quarantine like you weren't
interested in reading yeah you weren't
interested in a podcast book club but
now we're all having different interests
like I have a better time I have a
peloton in my home and you hear me talk
about peloton before quarantine you know
had no time for it yeah like I would
really recommend reading this book and
listening to 36 episode because I think
it's gonna be really fun and then like
you'll be a redhead for life my
interests like are pretty much the same
I think I'm even more set in my ways I
haven't worked out once and I'm just
like playing games and eating food and
watching TV so you're hanging your home
which I said you wouldn't do that's true
that's true I I'm drinking in my home
which I did again last night I'm just
loving the claw life you know and I I've
graduated like not that I even started
my freshman year but like I don't [ __ ]
those little claws cans like I just do
the big 40 ounce wine those are 170
calories what you really feel like isn't
bad right no I mean it's like two big
drink how are you don't exist no I know
and literally just ate like goldfish and
it's it feels like it's 10:00 in the
morning but it's actually quite light
yeah it is quite late also I didn't
mention but the book this month is
nothing to see here
by Kevin Wilson and even if you don't
have the book in you don't or you don't
have a Kindle you can get the Kindle app
on your iPhone or your iPad and you can
start reading and I know people are like
but I love the feeling of books and I
used to feel that way like who wants to
read on a little tablet thing but now I
can't read books well no they are so
heavy they hurt my wrist the quantity in
which you read like I will read maybe a
book a year and I do like having a
physical book I know but if you've
started to read on a Kindle you would
just enjoy it so much more now like all
these companies send me books and I have
all these books in my house and I'm like
can you send me the Kindle version yeah
a gift card because I'm supposed to hold
this book for hours yeah my wrists are
really suffering from the quarantine
like I'm getting really bad carpal
tunnel I actually put icy hot on my
wrists last night because I've been just
holding my phone so much
ya know I um breaking news you know
throw out my back again like just as it
was becoming heels loader he was up all
night like screaming in pain I have an
icy hot on right now like I see how it
is magic it is magic I put it all over
my body that's a smart way is it like a
cream that you have cream I see how
cream what do you have the patches
oh my back it looks like there's a big
white square on it I have the creme de
la creme oh so I need to go after this
to pick up more I see how cuz I'm on my
last one I also need more a minute rice
I know and rice is not everyone's
favorite food but it happens to be my
favorite food and when I've been cooking
every single meal I haven't ordered in
ones on my hot plate
I'm a cup rice pretty much with every
dish because it really goes with
everything like last night we did social
in rice is so good been made like a
chicken stir-fry you also need units all
tacos I mean you also need rice tacos
you also need rice so I've been trying
out different ones that I'm usually a
success brown rice girly but when I went
to the grocery store they didn't have it
so I just picked up minute white rice
and oh my god it's beautiful like it's
so good so flat beautiful it's so much
better and then I sent been out to get
rice and I'm like been minute white rice
but Ben is always used to getting
success that he didn't even think to
listen to me and he bought success he's
like look what I got you I got you the
big
big extra-large Park run rice and I'm
like Ben I said minute white not cool
man
so that's my life now just fighting
about rice but I'm not really that upset
yeah I realized I was high when I was
putting I see how that my body like how
many paint like how much pain I'm
constantly in like I get this weird
saying maybe like the toaster has it
I've had it ever since I was little
we're like sometimes late at night the
back of my leg just one leg kills like
hurts like throbs just like sore it's
just a griddle yeah it's like yeah I
can't explain what it is it's the back
of the leg late at night ever since I
was a kid at night like ever it happens
it's it's just rare like maybe once
maybe it'll happen twice in a week or
what it'll have them once yeah yeah it
but it's not pain it's almost like
cramps that I feel like the veins in my
legs are just alive like it's not
hurting me but I'm I can't go to bed
because I'm so hyper aware that my legs
are on the bed like it's like hey we're
the legs and we're alive like it's so
annoying and the only thing that helps
us to take Advil but by the way I just
really kinda advil that in the
quarantine times you shouldn't be taking
advil because there's like some
correlation between people who got
carnivores and I know and people who
have coronavirus who were otherwise
healthy who have taken advil or
acetaminophen as the drug in it that's
anti-inflammatory um that really makes
the difference in how severe their case
of coronaviruses I had my period this
weekend and I didn't take my dough
because I saw in the patio based on the
packet it said I'm open I don't think
I've had cramps and not taking my doll
in ten years like horrible it was crazy
I felt like I was going through like a
natural birth but that's awful I'm so
sorry as someone who literally I take at
least two advil every day because I get
headaches I got my leg cramps I just I
had a lot of problems I never realized
also but I'm just like feeling tired
sometimes they'll take Advil and I
haven't been able to take Advil in two
weeks and it's a crazy I mean been are
literally advil addicts like we both
just pop advil we have like a Costco
size Kirkland Advil like we just love
advil and we haven't been able to take
it in like two weeks and I'm genuinely
suffering but I feel like after this
whole mess is over I will have like now
a new built immunity to like not anti
immunity like I'm so immune to Advil
right now like I need four to really
feel it but now after this I feel like
I'm gonna take one Advil
oh my god sorry better crazy
advil I miss it excedrin like I miss all
those drugs Oh some what people are like
now talking about I can take a set
emotion I read somewhere not to take a
sudden move in and so I didn't take my
doll anyways my cramps they passed with
the Hank thinks of a heating pad the
heating pad has been one of the small
joys of my quarantine I have just made
everything a little bit better I've had
a few things like that
where it's like they're not major
improvements like it's not going to
change your life but it's like just a
small joy in an otherwise mundane day
what shape heating pad you out okay so I
have a pretty small rectangular one that
I always use for my cramps or my back or
anytime I have an ailment or I'm just
like really cold but Zack just ordered
like this beautiful new state-of-the-art
one and I don't want to give up my old
one cuz like I love her and she's been
so good to me
um but now he has this like big plush
one that's like velvet oh and it has
like two holes it's like for your feet
to go in have warm feeling yeah it's
good stuff so I have like the classic
you know like Duane Reade rectangular
heating pad but I feel like it's really
faulty like the way that it just like
slouches down my back I needed to have
some sort of belt like a harness that
can like maybe attach it to my neck or
just like probably nothing that it never
stays where I need it to stay yeah
problem I do I'm always like reaching up
apparently the way I'm saying a senemo
Phineas like so we're on wrong probably
like as a team eyghon yeah you guys when
I was talking about if you knew it is
not ingredient on the drug that starts
with AC eto just stay away to stay away
away exactly anyways so that's that's
the teal I can't believe I finished the
book already like but now I start
thinking about you know what it meant
what were the themes what did I take
away from it um I got a bunch of
questions because I said I would try and
get Ben's give Eugene ayahs kitchen
video up on our patreon yesterday I was
having so much trouble I almost had a
CBS punch the counter moment like I
checked my computer and I throw down the
couch and I was ready to literally put
it over my leg and snap it in half like
I was having so much trouble getting
these big files from my phone he would
have experience doing that ever since he
snapped the wrist
yes it was a steal someone's co-pirate
yeah and I just even this morning I was
working tirelessly to airdrop it was
just torture I'm 90% of the way there
the video has to be up today because
it's the last day of the month and I
will not rest until it's up but I join
you to know I worked all day I mean yes
today and I didn't even get like 10%
done it was so frustrating but it'll be
up today so if you're interested in
seeing Ben's cooking tutorial with his
alter-ego you've a June Ayodhya fire
it'll be available on our beach on
channel patreon.com slash the morning
toast acetaminophen is what it is I said
of my fin sounds fine yeah I don't
remember what I say was forward whatever
you guys knew what I was talking about
yeah I'm so excited for you feature
Niyaz video it's such a morning toast
I've seen bits and pieces and I'm really
excited to watch The Full Monty
I can't believe tomorrow's April it's
like when I've thought about April like
this is just not where I thought I were
supposed to be in Vegas this weekend we
were supposed to be a Megan and Friday
he's Ben's birthday like what the [ __ ]
do I do I don't know I told him
yesterday like he ain't get a present
it's like one one would I have gotten
something yeah
and like it's just so sad it's too sad
like maybe you guys should just ignore
the birthday and then like celebrate it
on July 3rd like or maybe all April
birthdays get pushed to June so like
June 3rd will be his birthday May July
2nd will be Zach's birthday because
whose weren't they supposed to be in May
you know like we're just gonna push him
all back can you have it done it's
annoying for people whose birthdays are
injured in July I mean at least you have
birthdays yeah I just I don't really
know what to do like shy even attempt to
like make it special with like a cake or
just like ignore its entire existence it
might be too sad to China especially you
know and I might just keep reminding him
but also he's like turning 29 2000 20 28
and he was born in 92
I'm 27 right guys know where the 28 20
years yeah well that's so old ill yeah I
mean my husband's turning 30 this year
oh we partying thriving oh my god so are
you yeah I feel like we're ready to be
30 it's all about where you're at in
your life and your age is only sad if
you're still acting like a child by the
way wow so [ __ ] true your age is only
sad if you're still acting like a child
like if you are where you're meant to be
when you're 30 and then it's not sad
like no if you leave it build in your
career in your relationship like totally
50 60 70 it's like you are an
established 50 60 set like wherever
you're in life like if you are where you
are supposed to be it is not sad that's
so true you know right like it's not sad
if you're turning 70 like you have
grandchildren you know right hopefully
yeah okay that's really good way to look
at it mm-hmm um so I
thing it might be I don't know I don't
have a watch and again time doesn't move
in quarantine but I'm fairly certain
that it's hmm I don't know I think so
really you're just gonna go ahead and
just I think we should say that it's
time even if maybe it wasn't time
you would die then you would say I would
say yeah I'm that certain that it's time
I would say I mean yeah I would say
you're just gonna yeah own it and say it
um okay so do you want me to say it are
you well actually yesterday you said
that you wanted to say it you know I
don't really like saying it look when
you say it without further ado it is
maybe perhaps probably time for the past
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast and that's true
but you know I don't know if anyone
knows this we have a very large mirror
in our studio and unfortunately it is in
my direction so when we're doing the
show Jack you can't see yourself but I
can and I'm just seeing how flat and
oily my hair is and I'm literally just
running waiting for the show to be over
so I can run home and go watch it
thanks to my function of beauty products
which is today's episode sponsor we all
know the frustration bottles on bottles
of half use shampoos and conditioners
piling up in your bathroom each one
promising to be everything your hair
ever needed but they lied to you they
were nice they were nothing of the sort
you deserved better
so try function a beauty we don't all
have the same hair so why should we all
use the same shampoo and conditioner now
you don't have to with function of
beauty if you're ready to live your best
hair life in 2020 then you need to know
everything about function of beauty it
is the internet's top rated customised
hair care brand with over 30,000
five-star customer reviews and Counting
if you have curly or straight natural or
processed hair function of beauty
individually formulates every bottle
based on your unique hair type style
preference and hair goals to begin the
short for question quiz and save 20% off
you on your first purchase could a
function of beauty.com slash toast you
tell them all about your hair even
customize your formula and fragrance in
color or you can go dye or fragrance
free the products are so personalized
your name is even printed on the bottle
plus function of beauty products are
vegan and cruelty-free they never use
sulfates parabens flat lights mineral
oils or any other harmful ingredients to
get started now go to function of Beauty
calm / toast to take your 4 part hair
profile quiz and save 20% off on your
first order do
spend another minute in her misery go to
function of beauty calm such toast to
let them know that we sent you
that's function of beauty.com / toast
sign on get your hair right I've been
loving my function of beauty eucalyptus
scented shampoo and conditioner that
matches my bathroom and you know who's
loving it even more because like the
bottles I was just going down and down
yeah Zack and it's like I only wash my
hair like twice a week yeah so I should
have more product sometimes I use a
little function to you because it smells
good he's a function in beauty queen I
mean he's beautiful so it's only right
that he would use a product use a
function of beauty no he is the function
of beauty he's the thought of beauty
that's what it is the fashion okay
first story something that everyone
except for me is talking about and I'm
gonna give you guys this tea mostly
because there was literally no other
stories today guys like it's getting
really bad by the way even the
laboratories are giving up when we first
think you know what I'm honestly God
because like they're so [ __ ] bored
and they keep putting their [ __ ] out on
us and making us like control me even
though like no one asked for it yeah but
now it's like the five stories it's like
it's getting but we was almost the
fast-forward when we first started our
quarantine videos we were like we are
gonna find the stories and we're not
gonna only talk about current of ours
and like we were so hell-bent but
literally there's genuinely nothing to
talk about
yeah except everyone is talking about
the tiger King which I think is a sign
of the times and how there's nothing to
talk about because I think if this show
came out you know at the height of
culture content um it would just you
know be like some weird little show that
came no I would have had like a day
where people were talking about it but
the level that people are obsessed with
it it's because shockingly not one
network or streaming service is really
capitalizing on people's demand for new
content and I can't believe that like
part of the reason this was definitely
an interesting story and it was like
funny and well done documentary but it
doesn't deserve to be spoken about as
much as it's being spoken about it and
that's only because it has literally no
other competition like I just can't
believe that Netflix and Hulu like
aren't just releasing stuff that they
have in the bank I know that they have
new shows new documentaries I know they
do because it's part of their job to
just constantly release content and
they're just really not taking advantage
of our needs it's frustrating it's
frustrating but Margot Robbie's name has
been tossed in the rain to play tiger
King Joe exotic and the headlines a
little misleading because it's really
just like this person on a podcast
saying that he thinks Margot Robbie
should play oh really
yeah but apparently this podcast guy
like has is connected to the
I'll take you prick this series is
adapted from a wandering odd cast so
while Kate McKinnon has already signed
on to play Carol Baskin but for this
adaption
oh the okay so there's a TV series going
around there's multiple things I had
also heard enough Lex is making a
musical about it but there is a legit
before that cast called Joe exotic Tiger
kiss yeah but I'm saying there's already
a project in the works that was in the
works before the documentary came out
and now people are talking about it it's
Kate McKinnon is a director and she has
cast herself to play Carol Baskin yes
and the host of the podcast Joe exotic
tiger King Robert Moore says while Sam
Rockwell's name has been mentioned for
to play Joe in the casting which by that
he would be great he actually robert
moore wants margot robbie to play oh so
he was but he's just the podcast so he's
basically like the author of a book that
gets adapted I don't think that gives
him much say in casting because once you
sell the rights like you're selling your
soul but I don't hate this
people were really confused because
obviously like she's a girl and Joe
exotic is a boy but she's very good like
she's a really transformative Karen yeah
I mean if she can play Tonya Harding to
meet her being no offense like ugly
Tonya Harding she could be a man like
that's not as crazy no it's it's not as
crazy she really is a chameleon and I
feel like she would be up for the job
but I also feel like there's plenty of
people who could and everyone is like
throwing their hat in the ring like Doc
Shepard is being so toasted blow Diplo
would be great
Jared Leto is being thrown around I
think that um Sam Rockwell it actually
be great but I don't know if Sam
Rockwell and Margot Robbie would do TV
they're movie stars
it's miniseries it's different I know
but think about it has either of them
ever done TV um miniseries probably Sam
Rockwell yeah I don't know when you're
just like an actual movie star like you
for sure gonna win an Oscar like every
year like miniseries is a great way to
like win to sweep and until I get things
in categories that you wouldn't normally
go for and to ego and not and like to
not waste too much of your time yeah I
guess I just have a hard time seeing
Margot Robbie really doing anything
other than like movie stardom yeah I
don't know I think it's it's a big
stretch also for other castings more
said that he wanted john c reilly from
you know stepbrothers to play da cantle
oh my god wait that's a [ __ ] amazing
call yeah I don't even know these people
and it feels like a good call the
frustration that I have with this whole
documentary and part of the reason every
was like recap and assign it for totes
movie honestly it wasn't that good I
know we're all brainwashed because we
have nothing to watch right now if it
had been the two-and-a-half hour
documentary like one movie I would have
maybe liked it more I thought it was an
interesting story the documentary didn't
highlight enough how [ __ ] up all these
people are for breeding exotic animals
literally there's 4,000 exotic tigers
left and half them are living in zoos in
America why like I just feel like it
didn't harpin up unlike the severity of
the actual issue and yeah there was like
funny things about it like the music
video but like the whole documentary was
just so silly and so drawn-out oh my god
like that whole episode about him
running for president like it was just
so drawn out but the guy's interesting
and the documentary filmmaker is in
contact with geo exotic who spoiler
alert is in prison for 27 years and he
knows that he's now become famous
because the Netflix documentary and he's
like so excited about that's exciting
do we like him I mean he was not a great
guy but there were much worse guys
involved and I'm pretty sure that they
framed him so like he did the thing that
he I don't know he he was a bad guy but
he was definitely framed a little bit so
we don't dislike him I mean he was so
funny haha Tigers his music kind of
loves it sounds beautiful
I don't what you're singing and it's a
song that's now viral on tick-tock like
everyone's like doing
tick tock stuff oh that's cool I mean I
posted three tic tacs yesterday but I
didn't catch that one oh you didn't know
I haven't seen any problem interests and
also Sam Rockwell did just do Fosse
burden so like I feel like he would be
good for TV I actually think it it's
beneath Margot Robbie yeah yeah I don't
like to go like all these people being
thirsty like you're really seeing the
thirst of people like taking advantage
of a quarantine like Jack Shephard I'm
sorry Jack Shephard is you hear he's
really not an actor like he was in baby
mama and like I was a podcaster and like
saying you're like Daniel a we're gonna
say Arlene you stay in the joke yeah I
feel like I should be playing too exotic
obviously um I just feel like we have
such similar like looks if they offered
you the role but you have to cut he has
basically like half bangs would you do
it um of course I'd haven't seen the
script it has to be a surefire like Nami
I mean look
people are talking about it it's got to
know but then you look like the
laundromat and like you would think like
right just because something is
star-studded barely lethal doesn't mean
that it would be good right right like
laundromat can't even get nominated for
jokes movie of the day ha ha ha barely
lethal could tamela's Steven Soderbergh
Meryl Streep Gary Oldman and also we
just because something is star stud
isn't star-studded doesn't mean it's bad
head over heels didn't know one person
in that movie except Freddie Prinze jr.
and it's literally the best movie I've
ever seen yeah I can't wait to watch it
again I totally and I'm so grateful I
had the stars up no I mean the stars app
is amazing like I yeah it is you know it
is cause like they it has all the stars
when I had my fire stick usually if I
search something it'll take me like
Netflix Hulu the big guns like stars is
always like last on the list so I never
make it but head over heels was weirdly
like not available anywhere except stars
but I had it and I loved the app it's
such good movies I'm not saying you can
get stars that's like only we used to
watch movies like growing up what we had
every channel like yeah encore stars
would have the best ones but you could
enact stars for free for seven days with
Hulu and then I fell in love with it and
then just start paying for it because we
will pay for content in these times if
someone will just give it to us yeah by
the way and I never realized because you
need a stars you need a cable login that
has stars to get into the stars app I
pay for cable like I have all the movie
channels because I wanted to be like the
cool house where everyone would one like
come over and watch football even though
I don't even let anyone come to my house
I need to cut down my cable bill like I
literally pay for HBO stars I have all
them and I've never used them but I like
having the login for my fire stick so
I'm torn yeah it's tough stuff okay next
story big story of the day CNN anchor
Chris Cuomo has been diagnosed with
coronavirus he will continue working
from home when I saw this people like
Cuomo has coronavirus I mean you say
Cuomo you mean and you mean big coma if
you run it like he's the only Cuomo who
doesn't require a first name so if
you're gonna say just the last thing
people are obviously gonna think the
more famous more Christmassy just one so
literally my heart sank I was the one
dip already know the one with a nipple
just Chris just Andrew Cuomo governor
I'm sorry Governor Cuomo have a nipple
ring so in a press conference yesterday
he was wearing like a really kind of
spelt like white collared shirt and some
girl on Twitter
screenshot at a part of the press
prints we're like his nipple gets a
little hard and you could see like you
know the two balls get the two balls
exactly on either side symmetrical sides
of the areola and then I saw another
picture of him walking out of the press
conference which was like a high-tech
paparazzi camera and the nipple ring is
very much there so I'm pretty certain
that he hasn't already I feel as though
like that wouldn't be the craziest thing
I ever heard I feel like Governor Cuomo
just like he's a governor during the day
and like just like a madhouse badass at
night no I didn't actually you know like
such a good job right now because he is
a badass and he's just like taking on
this virus yeah and the corona virus
like really needs like a maverick to
attack you know I didn't even find it to
be shocking I just liked it I thought it
was shocking that he got caught yeah
yeah and every time I like learn
something new about him like it's just
he's not even surprising me I feel like
I know him so well and to be honest like
we've been saying a lot of people are
thinking he's gonna run for the office
of president after all this is done
because people are really like inspired
by his leadership skills and if we get a
president who has a nipple ring like I
will be so excited do you think that he
would be the first president with an if
whirring do you think there's not in all
the 40 Neil Clinton was a little you
know freaky deaky maybe he had one and
like took it out like got it one night
yes like took it out and it closed up I
think I don't know if he would be the
first but it would be the first that we
know about because and he has to address
it I'm sorry like absolutely silence is
deafening yeah and it's like what are
you hiding and so Chris Cuomo is still
gonna heat he's been home doing CNN from
his like basement for the last few days
and he's gonna continue to be on the air
they said he should only showing mild
symptoms yeah he's feeling well and will
continue to anchor his 9:00 p.m. program
Cuomo primetime from his home quote in
these difficult times that seemed to get
more difficult and complicated by the
day I just found out that I am positive
for coronavirus he wrote in a message on
Twitter I had been exposed to people in
recent days who have subsequently tested
positive and I had fevers chills and
shortness of breath
I just hope I didn't give it to the kids
at Christina that would make me feel
worse than this illness yeah that's like
so sad it's like obviously you're upset
you get coronavirus but then you think
about all the people you could be
killing yeah excuse me yes you yeah no I
actually found out that three people
that I was with the first week of March
all tested positive for coronavirus a
lot of people that I know have
yeah but I was with them but now I'm
past the 14-day period
I've been past 40 day period for a while
but I only recently found out that they
had it it's like what is the proper like
social requirements when it comes to
coronavirus is it like an STD like you
have you know chlamydia you have to tell
your last few partners like you have to
tell the last few people that you
stopped don't call people and tell them
like if you know when you were exposed
to it you call the people that you've
seen between then and now and what if
you don't know where you got it from
yeah a lot of people at least some
people that I know who have it they are
able to identify where they got it from
I know two people who have it who don't
know where they got it from Wow which
means they could have just gotten it
like respite orally or like touched an
elevator but yet like from the community
and that's like a scary way yeah that is
the scary way cuz that like really can't
be avoided by quarantining like you
could just accidentally touch the button
in your elevator know for sure but no
but if you don't even go to your
elevator look if you have a dog yeah
well if you're wearing gloves I do when
you wash your hands and you don't touch
your face in the time between it
actually cadmium yeah I just there's no
but you know what can't be avoided like
if you're walking down the street to
walk your dog and like anybody been in
the air for three hours which is what
people are saying can happen even though
dr. Burke psych was kind of on the fence
about and she didn't say one word the
one way or the other if it
she's like anything can happen you know
that's the vibe I was getting was that
like she doesn't think so but she
doesn't want to say it because I'm sure
there's one case in China you know where
someone got it so I I was getting the
vibe that she didn't want to get to like
me to relax right or not like likely and
that's not how it's really being passed
all the time but like anything could
happen yeah anything can happen
that's what's so crazy about carnivals
y'all um so Governor Cuomo let the
people know that his brother had
coronavirus didn't you know he obviously
is supportive and did not miss the
opportunity to roast him and tell him
that he's not as strong as he thinks he
is I absolutely love brothers Cuomo like
brothers Arab and yes
no they need to do you know how AC to
Andy Cooper Anderson Cooper and Andy
Cohen like go on tour and neither one of
them like have like a tour towel and
they just like sit drink and like be
funny and take questions I need a
governor and an ad Chris like a Cuomo
squared like live event you know yeah
maybe they can live podcast tour and eco
and speaking of celebrities who are
recovering Andy Cohen is pretty
recovered from coronavirus he was be he
was able to be reunited with his son
which is like so sad I didn't even
realize that they probably had to be
separated and he's back now on the air
they're doing watch weapons I'd like
from home and they had nene leakes and
her connection was okay
they're Jerry O'Connell who's that
internet literally brought down the
entire show it was really frustrating
you watch it on TV you know I watched it
on clips and all I saw was a blurry ass
Jerry O'Connell it's I'd rather just see
Andy talk for 30 minutes or just like
give me a rerun I love those watch trap
inside specials where they put together
like the 10 craziest moments on watch
Robins life running like for the whole
time great I loved The Real Housewives
of New York season 10 reunion and I
think there's another reunion starting
today I saw at 6 a.m. so I'm I love that
like gimme give me you know give me Real
Housewives of DC you know keep me Real
Housewives of Miami yeah I'll take a
read
I'll take go let's play The Real
Housewives of Miami live reunion that
they did how about that yeah I don't
think they want to relive that but like
what about some and my see prep you know
I think you back what about gallery
girls yeah
gallery girls is on the Bravo app which
I was using to watch how's the sunset
the other day and I almost clicked it
but that show was just like so lame hey
days yeah that was the problem with like
all the NYC shows that Bravo tried to do
like NYC prep gallery girls like
princesses Long Island yeah they just
wanted to get like this cool subculture
of like rich cool people and I know a
lot of rich cool people and literally
everyone they got on these shows was the
opposite of rich and cool yeah look
their apartments were sad their
personalities were sad was just a
terrible show terrible terrible
princesses Long Island was an actual
like I found you know it was a travesty
and I'm princess who briefly lived in
Long Island it was a Travis I feel like
the chief rabbi should have called up
those girls have been like you are an
embarrassment yeah I know the fact that
they just went on that show and acted
the way that they did in the name of
being Jewish like was a disgrace to our
entire religion and like really made me
ashamed and I don't know I just think
that like as Jews and I'm sure maybe
every minority feels this way I feel
like people just hate Jews like for
whatever reason you know they just feel
like it and we're always combating that
like random hatred for no reason and
people going on TV and being dumb and in
the name of Judaism like you're giving
our doctors oh purpose to hey that's
like Oh what I know why I hated Jews but
now they're being annoying like an
snotty like now let me have them for
real like I literally hate that show so
much
agreed um yeah are you ready for our
next story no I'm not because
I needed to talk about something I'm
just as passionate about princess long
island as I am about my hush blanket and
I'm being dead [ __ ] serious yeah I'm
[ __ ] serious
I read for my book six hours straight
last night like under my husband and
that's why I couldn't move yeah look I
was just trapped by the anti-anxiety
I slept under my hush blanket and also I
took some extra hush material and put it
under my head for like a pillow to
support my back it was fabulous I'm
obsessed with my way to blanket I never
thought I would be the type of person
who needs a weighted blanket because
some of them I see online they're a
little ugly and they look like hospital
blankets but the hush ones are velvet I
have a navy blue one that matches my
navy blue pillows on my bed it is so
fabulous there are a lot of benefits of
having a weighted blanket you can get a
deeper sleep you can stay asleep longer
it genuinely feels like a hug and has
really proven to help people who
experience anxiety and stress and hush
blankets which is my absolute favorite
they also have a giveback program so
they donate one to one in 10 adult
blankets and one in five kids blankets
to charities and shelters in need it's
been a huge part of their brand since
day one and they understand that not
everyone can afford a hush but they
absolutely deserve the experience to
better sleep the one that I haven't I
think the one that you have is the throw
and it comes in different colors and you
can also there's different sizes so like
you know you wouldn't need the same
weight size as me like because we're
different weights you know like we you
know and also because I have a queen bed
you have a king bed like yeah one that's
gonna span your bed and so I just
absolutely love it and I really feel
really passionately about it they have a
100 night guarantee which is you get a
hundred nights to test out the blanket
if you don't love it send it back to
them for a full refund no questions
asked
if you feel like your blanket is too
light or too heavy you can exchange
sizes returns and exchanges are super
easy and the code that we have for you
guys is chose so if you go to their
website which is hush blankets calm use
the code toast for $50 off all weighted
blankets so you have to go to hush
blankets calm the code is toast toas tea
for $50 off always blankets thank you
hush for sponsoring this episode and for
making a fabulous product love it sinon
be better off during quarantine honestly
how flank it is a perfect sponsor for
the quarantine and so is our next stage
one of those small joys that is keeping
me going and literally you can say the
same about the next sponsor so what's
next bounce I mean I don't want to spoil
it but just give us a ticket start ease
it starts with an F and ends with
Earth's leaf o firstly that's your
yes okay we'll get into it but bad baby
calls out her friend Billy Eilish for
ghosting her oh my god I'm like who is
bad baby and yes hurt it's not bad baby
is it I don't know her instrument
spelled BH ad
BH a bie I'm going bad baby
I go bad Bobby like I'm Bobby okay I
don't know I don't know it's just like I
said I'm oh Finley I'm sorry it's it's
irrelevant
it appears that Danielle burger Leigh is
looking to start something with Billy
Eilish the troubled teen come verse
viral sensation that is the perfect way
to describe her the troubled teen yeah
made a name for herself as a cash me
outside girl I'm dr. Phil show she
hosted a QA over Instagram I this past
weekend because she is just another
board a celebrity giving us something
that nobody asked for yet here we are
talking about it it was there that she
was asked about her relationship with
the five-time Grammy winner for those
who don't know the pair struck struck up
a friendship over social media before
Billy Eilish his career really took off
they were even photographed together on
multiple occasions okay so by the way I
had no idea about anything either so now
according to ding Albergo Li this Billy
Eilish won't even return her DMS quote I
think I'm friends with Billy I don't
know if Billy's my friend every time i
DM her and give her my number she just
doesn't text me so I don't know I mean I
guess that's what happens when [ __ ]
get famous she added I'm not tripping I
know who my real friends are I just have
to say that's not what happens when
people get famous like if junior goalie
was just like a normal teenage like
thirst monster like a Madison beer I'm
sure that she would still be friends
with Billy Eilish but like Billy Eilish
is a Grammy winner she cannot be rolling
around town with the likes of Danielle
Berg Olli
no she really can't like jr. burger Lee
is a [ __ ] stain on America alecko's
right like even if Billy Eilish like
absolutely loved and adored being
Albergo Lee like from the bottom of her
heart like her team was like listen you
can't be friends what has happened to
you is an anomaly like you are like
obviously very talented but there are a
lot of talented people like you have
gotten to where you are and it's truly
it's a miracle and like there's one
thing that could detract everything and
it's a few being friends with bad baby
burger Lee and I really respect Billy
Eilish I'm sure she liked bad burger Lee
whatever the [ __ ] her name is and she
misses her as a friend but you know what
sometimes in life friendships aren't
meant to last forever no they're
definitely not and this is one that had
an expiration date yeah and it
what it is it is what it is you know
very sad I mean I had no idea that they
were friends I would love to see some
pictures of them photograph exist I'm
going to literally Google that later but
it kind of like makes sense like Billy
Eilish has it's like bad girl vibe so
like no I could see them being friends
it just so happens I mean Billy Alex
just also so talented and like yeah but
you know what they're actually quite
different because Billy Eilish has this
like bad girl vibe just because her hair
is green but she's actually like a
really soft spoken like young cool girl
who has like a lot of like thoughts
about feminism you know yeah so she's
actually like it probably has nothing in
common with bad baby Bertolli yeah I
don't know oh my god I just remembered I
had a terrible dream back on in jail you
know that's like literally my biggest
fear and I got in trouble with like a
bunch of my friends for like doing
something with drugs and literally I was
the only one who got seven years in jail
and before I went to jail I called you
and I was like Jackie literally I'm God
I was like email the White House because
we have their email like get me partner
it's like I was already screaming crying
I was so afraid to go to prison and then
I went and I saw my friend Nikki in
prison which was weird but she was there
for some other events and so it was I
able to help oh no like literally no one
was like I called you on my my phone
call at jail and you were like Claudia
we've literally tried everything we're
talking to everyone but like no one can
help and I was literally like called
Simon Huck get Kim Kardashian and get me
pardoned Wow well that leads us to our
next story because Kim Kardashian says
the family is filming the season 18
finale at home on their iPhones the
finale of Keeping Up with the
Kardashians is going to look a little
different this season on Monday k'kaw
joining Jimmy Fallon be a video chat for
an episode of The Tonight Show at home
edition oh I didn't realize that's
pretty cool I would watch her where she
revealed how the corona virus pandemic
has affected production of the family
show currently in its 18th season quote
we film the entire season except for the
last episode so now that we've shut down
production it'll be all of us in
quarantine filmed separately by
ourselves we have tripod set up and our
iPhones and the whole last episode will
be what we do in quarantine
I'll get to see what Khloe's doing I
mean I literally have no idea what
anywhere else has been doing I mean
that's fine but it's annoying that it's
the finale I would love to just know
what's going on in the Kardashian world
and what the storyline is by the end of
the season like I'm sure there's so
drama with Courtney and all the filming
stuff so I hope that gets resolved and I
don't want to see that play out in
FaceTime No
no but like that's right now like we
have like these Earth's still have like
so many episodes before the finale and
they filmed all those episodes but now
like is when they would be filming what
would be the last episode and instead
it's it's this is what they're actually
doing being in quarantine but I wonder
why they didn't just make the most
recent episode the finale maybe you can
edit it yeah and it probably like was
left on an open note and also they have
like contracts in place they have to
film a certain amount of a precise
amount of time and I'm episodes so I
feel like this is cool it's like a
little patreon video from them yeah
they're really taking a page out of the
toast book of life yeah I feel like
that'll be a good patreon for next month
like a day in the life of quarantine
okay yeah a lot Jimmy Fallon's doing
from home James Corden's doing from home
too and they had the cast of you will be
fast
the cast of dear Ivan Hanson and Ben
Platt doing like a Lady Antebellum needs
you now like they put everyone's videos
together with all the high raise to you
it was actually done quite well oh cool
yeah Ben Platt was the star Jordan
Fisher who like plays the role of Ben
Platt like God like a little box in the
corner he was like irrelevant oh that's
nice for him yeah yeah that song is
really inspirational I always get chills
I am just like getting so testy with all
of this like celebrity content I can
tell you like I love them hot I loved
your attention and actually you will be
found might be my favorite song but like
I have no interest no I know I have no
interest like so like Hollywood is like
oh something sad is happening Ben pot oh
yeah yeah but you know what it works I
guess I don't know but then he did a
whole live and like didn't even saying
like that was day maybe he learned from
that and he's correcting it but I'm just
like I don't know I'd rather talk to
like you guys and my friends then like
deal with like right now celebrities to
me are irrelevant it's like I don't like
Fame what's things yanno doesn't matter
Governor Cuomo actually said something
really brilliant today on his press
conference he said
coronavirus excuse me coronavirus is the
great equalizer like no matter how rich
how poor like you are just as
susceptible as someone else so honestly
it's like celebrity like right now is
like celebrity culture like doesn't
really exist
no like being famous means absolutely
nothing but it does probably mean that
you have a pool and a place and so I'm
jealous and actually that makes me want
to watch your [ __ ] even less because I
don't want to see what I don't have I
know like Chrissy Teigen hosted this
live stream like of her to like teddy
bears getting married it was so dumb but
like they were on their back porch
I think they're Malibu beach house and
it was just so stunning and fabulous and
it was like so luxurious and I actually
just want to throw my phone in the
garbage you made me so sad I'm like
looking at my TV for the 45th time a day
yeah also like I guess people are are
watching it and enjoying it so like
maybe good for them like there's a whole
host of people who are who are
interested in that content I just I
don't know if I expected myself to be
one of those people but I'm just not I'm
nothing of the sort
and that's my cross to bear and by the
way this week I've act like I think like
last week like warranty was still it
kind of funny and interesting and like
this week it's just not know so I know
it's not like not really even posted on
Instagram I'm just like I'm over
everything
yeah this week it's really not it's it's
really dire like I was watching the news
last night I don't know why and like
because it's just so like inundated with
negativity like sometimes when I look
for stories in the morning like I do
find like some really positive stories
like Johnson and Johnson is doing
amazing news a lot of companies are a
lot of companies are doing really cool
things I saw on Instagram this video did
you see that bellick and this video of
the masks that they're making oh no
Bella canvas is an apparel company we
use them a lot of their stuff for our
merch and they have converted their
factory they've like state-of-the-art
factories into these mask making
machines and wow they have found a way
to make masks that don't require any
stitching basically it's two holes at
the side that you plug your wires into
they are able to make a million masks a
day and it's like that's what I want to
be seeing on the news I only saw that on
Instagram like I want to see it on the
news Wolf Blitzer that's fabulous yes on
Instagram I saw Jonathan sim Chi
interact with Governor Cuomo's instrum
Sen like we have a full factory like
what do you need like look how I'm
Christian Siriano did that too yeah so
yes I agree I also heard Bob Iger is
foregoing his salary and a bunch of
executives are taking a pay cut yeah
which I thought was fabulous fabulous
like that's what I love to see and
unless I seek out those stories like I
don't see that I just showed you like
the good stuff is really not being
spoken about enough even when I went to
crostinis to pick up groceries like a
week ago
there was a huge sign in the window that
said 7:00 to 8:00 a.m. the grocery store
is closed for anyone like under the age
of 60 which is so yeah I've seen that
too really really sweet but then I just
wonder like how are the seniors getting
that information you know I see it on
Instagram it's like they're not on
Instagram so it's can some like they
know they have a sign up in the store
so I guess if the senior comes to the
store I don't know that's a really good
we need a better way to get seniors
information like we need little like
leaflets left under their door yes how
seniors read like that's how the other
information yeah or the newspaper yeah
whatever it is like we got to get the
seniors I'm sure that like local
newspapers are filled with that kind of
information and the only people who read
the local newspapers that you get for
free in the subway are but they're not
taking the subway
no but they definitely subscribe to them
okay okay should we dive into our recap
because I'm really really excited about
it dive right in okay so our twist movie
of the day yesterday was head over heels
and we're gonna recap it and assigned
tomorrow's movie and the sponsor of this
segment very appropriately is first leaf
wines um convenience is everything right
now we love having whatever we want to
live at our door and wine is no
exception if you want to discover new
wine without the work a try first leaf
so it's basically one subscription
service it's everything of the sort they
make it's so easy for you to find new
wines and as someone who's currently
drinking in her house and just recently
took up like wine as a hobby I
absolutely adore foot for sleep and I
love that I get so many models because
like I said like sometimes you just need
a bottle a night and I didn't know that
that was a thing until now
first leaf removes the hassles and
guesswork of buying wine by expertly
selecting wines based on your unique
preferences what's not to love about
coming home to a personalized box of
wine the cool part is that first leave
uses your ratings and feedback to refine
each shipment so you could also choose
what types of wine you get let's say
you're throwing a party you want more
red blends first leaf will modify future
shipments firstly adds wine to their
inventory every month so you'll always
have something different to look forward
to unboxing my box of wine is half the
fun subscriptions are super flexible you
can choose when and how often you get
shipments first leaf has 100%
satisfaction guarantee so if you've
received a bottle that you aren't into
first leaf will cover the cost sign up
today and get six bottles of wine for
only $29.95 plus free shipping just go
to try first leaf dot-com slash toast
that's six bottles of wine for only
$29.95 plus free shipping at try first
leaf dot-com slash toast my absolute
favorite thank you so much firstly for
sponsoring this segment so I wrote down
my notes if you watch the movie it was
so fabulous it was called head over
heels I've seen it a million times like
as a kid my kid we used to watch it like
what
probably once a week we probably had a
bunch of movies on rotation we probably
watched like three movies a day so we
were watching like 21 movies a week and
this was one of those 21 movies
spiceworld was also that would be a good
movie um it was also one of those movies
and to be honest I had pretty much I
know that she lives with models but I
didn't even know he was like an FBI
agent like I forgot about all that stuff
I mean the storyline was like cute and
whatever but I have a lot of thoughts my
first is that the movie was sensational
and I think that the models who lived in
the house were the best part of the
whole movie they were so funny they took
really got into this character like they
were just so different and dynamic that
girl Halle was beautiful and so cute and
candy with her crazy uncle Pete like
they all were just really a great little
dessert I know but they were all really
great actresses like I was just so
surprised at how they really like
carried the movie yeah and like the
character development like they weren't
just like bitching like broad-stroke
models like they each had their own
personalities and flair and things that
they brought to the table and they were
like you we know that we're waterfront
property in the Hamptons right now but
in a few years we're gonna be apartments
in New Jersey and like we need a real
relationship like I just I loved the the
progress that they all made and I just I
thought they were such good friends and
they were so nice to her from the second
that they did her great advice yes and
they also like shared their clothes and
hair and makeup and it's just like as a
viewer that's just what you want to see
well then that brings me to the makeover
when they all got her dressed for that
party at Jim Winston's across the street
but and by the way did they live in the
same building or not no but she saw him
in the lobby with the dog huh I was so
give you somebody was a building that
like goes up and over like there's my
chair now yeah cuz I was like how the
[ __ ] do they keep me buzzing about
seeing complex like a kid because also
when she left the party she went down
the stairs and he came running remember
so they were in the same building yeah
okay was a complex it was confusing but
baby but so when they got her all
dressed like she literally looked
horrible I was so shook her makeup was
[ __ ] heinous and that outfit she was
like I can't go out I'd look like a
prostitute I'm like you literally
wearing a dress to the floor like how
the [ __ ] do you look like a resident
like she just looks so lame like her
makeup was so like russian prostitute
and she looked terrible yeah did you not
agree no I thought she is so cute like
I'd like to ensure the Vic herself
terrible no I didn't expect her to look
like a model like she was obviously
feeling herself like she was a little
snatch lured like it was an improvement
for much
but have warned like I'm here for it um
another thing I thought about the movie
was at the cat main character what was
her name
Monica Potter a man Amanda she was like
so desperate like I just some of the
stuff she was like acting and sang was
really bothering me because you know you
would think like why is this girl she
lives in New York she's a beautiful girl
she has a fabulous job at the Met like
she can't catch a break and it's like
actually it makes a lot of sense she was
insane like she was so desperate and she
was just like losery and like it was
every lies attracted Luther he tried
totally yeah we didn't meet he's sick
knees and then like oh I love your big
dog dick bit like she was just being so
dumb sometimes she was really bothering
me yeah I totally agree the funniest
part of the movie is when Jim Winston
takes a [ __ ] in his bathroom
okay so I remember as a kid literally
dying at that scene like literally that
was the first have anything in my life
like I silently laughed to the point
where like I thought I was gonna like
[ __ ] my pants and it hit just as hard I
loved it and then they opened the window
and asking for air and Holly's like well
no don't go in there
it's the funniest see it like literally
him just like with his tie over his
shoulder newspaper and the girls like
and that's like such dumb potty humor
which I normally didn't I but it was so
well they normally don't go for it but
it was so well and when the brunette
models like literally has her hands on
the shower wall and she's like it was so
funny that whole scene and then Amanda's
in the living room I thought it was very
very funny - yes agreed I need to know
what apartment by the Met is $500 a
month later he was such a nice apartment
like literally duplex multiple like just
crazy that closet and she's paying $5
for it but she said she lives a block
away from the met because she said she
walked to work yeah so Upper East Side
mm-hmm
$500 a month and I get that you know
inflation like okay whatever a thousand
still okay say it would be a thousand
but she's also living with five four
girls
yeah and they did say that the agency
pays for the apartment and the room that
she paid for it looks like $500 a month
worth like she got access to the rest of
the apartment cuz they liked her but
like if she was just a tenant in the
room like
very sad that's true for me like the
movie had one major flaw hmm and that
was that Jim Winston's real name was Bob
Smoot I wasn't sure if they did that
like to be funny or they really thought
that was a good name Bobby's new toes
because like Jim when he was Jim Winston
it's like razzle dazzle he's too good to
be true and it's like oh no he's just
Bob
yeah because honestly the second he said
Bob Smoot I stopped thinking it was cute
yeah maybe it was meant to like drive
home that point probably like that he
was so anti Jim Winston like he was just
a smooth and Jim Winston is such like a
fabulous New York fashion executive like
Harry saw James Oh Rose James Winston
yeah but Bob smooth I guess there was
probably a reason to it it just really
bothered me
ya know I think I think it was good and
then the other thing that I wanted to
say about the movie that year again and
I have seen those three old ladies who
worked in the restoration department
with her were so funny and cute and when
she slaps her judges out like it was
just so funny and I didn't realize that
that woman said the red beans thing
because she was deaf so she didn't
understand anything that was going on
and she was just like um we're gonna
have red beans but I hope it's really I
just can't think of like beans as a food
group without thinking of that movie you
know and you know and it's better to
think of that than like beans be they're
good for your heart the more you eat
them the more you fart the more you
start the better you feel so eat beans
at every meal so I think that was in a
fabulous election it was a little harder
to find than I would have liked and
normally we try and choose things that
are only on Netflix but to be honest
like Netflix is trash and I'm sorry that
we want to watch a good movie yes
Slick's is trash I'm we were starting
with only Netflix and that's why the
first week pics were trashed cuz Netflix
is trashed but for today's movie but
it's not only a play no we were gonna
choose what we were gonna choose but
member of music and lyrics yeah no okay
but that'll be at some other point this
week okay so today's movie is not music
and lyrics no it is she-devil starring
Roseanne Barr and overweight and unkempt
woman who can see me just give it away
okay
certain Roseanne Barr and Meryl Streep
and iconic - and Ed Begley Jr it is such
a good movie I have to shout out my
friend Rachel Ashton or Ford literary
texts me yesterday she was like I
haven't seen this me
so long it has to be toast movie of the
day it's so good I haven't seen it in
forever I think I know the basic premise
but I don't really remember a lot of the
details I just know that Meryl Streep is
like so fabulous and it's so fabulous
she's like a romance writer very rich
who has like this Pink Palace yeah her
her whole vibe is fabulous um so while
it's not on Netflix it is available a
lot of places so it is free on YouTube
so there's literally like a YouTube
video that's an hour and a half long and
the home movies there it's free on Vudu
if you subscribe it is also available on
prime and iTunes for 399 each so I think
$4 is a fair price for this fabulous
movie it is so crazy so excited to watch
it honestly I think us picking all these
old movies is really inspiring my like
stylist for sure I've been bringing out
the butter fried clips which I've owned
for six months but I never wear them
it's also very Lexy in a little fires
everyone know same like I've really just
been influenced by like this 90s I
almost wore a whole crown of butterfly
clips today but then I just like didn't
go with my sweat suit um but I'm loving
this like I think those were some of the
greatest times for style and fashion and
I'm so here for it and then and head
over heels was like not nineties it was
early 2000s but it was still like that
the styles were iconic like when the
models were just getting dressed like go
actual 7 a.m. with the like the men
waiting outside the apartment I just I
thought it was the highest level of
fabulousness
I completely agree and I'm so glad we
chose that movie it made me so happy I
literally had a breakdown about my
[ __ ] computer and like not being able
to get these files that I just decided
to take a break and watch the movie and
I was so happy like it was such a good
movie wow I'm so happy for you that the
movie could do that for you I'm so glad
we're on a great choice kick yeah and I
think this movie is sensational and I
know a lot of people don't like Roseanne
Barr but like just try and put that out
of your mind because first of all she
looks so different in movie you're gonna
forget that it was even her yeah and in
terms so long ago it's called she-devil
and its iconic you probably have seen it
and so if you've seen it you know it's
amazing you're gonna watch it again if
you haven't seen it like you're in for a
treat
you're in for a treat you're in for like
a real twist and turn of a movie you
know lots of different twists and turns
yeah yeah for sure is that it that's it
I just want to remind people that my
shirt is new merch and also I just want
to like explain inventories because this
shirt is actually it's a it's long
sleeves it's pretty long but I cropped
mine I'll show you
whoo oh it has lips and then shut in the
back
Canton shan't and went so it's really
cute we'll give you guys updates on when
this drop is coming and we'll show you
guys new items as they when we feel like
it now that we know that the drop is
coming we'll start wearing our stuff yes
I felt bad when we weren't gonna be able
to sell it so we weren't gonna like t
see what yeah but we're really excited
about it I love this shirt and there's
some really cool stuff to come it's a
really cool spring cleaning bag which is
what spring should be about instead of
corn clean vibes thank you guys so much
for listening to the morning toast we go
live Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m.
Eastern Time on YouTube this week we are
going live at 12:00 noon Eastern Time
some people on the west coast can join
us so if you're currently watching us on
YouTube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcasts can be found so that's Spotify
iTunes stitcher Public Radio I got radio
cast box all the places whoever you
listen to podcast find us the morning to
us and leave a five star review about a
beautiful stunning and smart we are we
love you guys so much bye tomorrow